a las múltiples crisis que atraviesa el
líbano se suma ahora una crisis
diplomática con los países del golfo
después de que anoche a arabia saudi
haya llamado a su embajador a retirarse
en 48 horas y prohibiera a la
exportación de todos los productos y a
sus ciudadanos viajar a el líbano el
incidente diplomático fue provocado por
unas declaraciones del ministro de
información afín al partido hezbollah
que hace unos meses dijo en una radio
pública saudí que los útiles tenían el
derecho de defenderse si estaban siendo
atacados cabe recordar que arabia saudi
lidera una coalición que está luchando
contra los rebeldes hutíes en el yemen
desde 2015 siguiendo a la decisión de
riad también el reino de baherin ha
llamado a su embajador a retirarse y ha
cortado las exportaciones el líbano
importa prácticamente todos sus
productos alimenticios por lo que esta
medida afectará todavía más la vida de
los libaneses que ya están sufriendo de
una escasez de alimentos de medicinas y
también de falta de ciudad que más que
falta de electricidad es una ausencia
total ya que cortes de luz más de 20
horas diarias a esta nueva crisis
diplomática con los países del golfo ha
provocado una agitación política y ha
llevado a los partidos de la oposición a
pedir la dimisión del primer ministro
nayib mitaki